Transcriber: KARIM BLEU
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
أهلًا وسهلًا بكم ومرحبا في هذا الحدث
العظيم المتميز بوجودكم.
أتحدث اليوم عن العبقرية.
معكم سيد الراوي معلم مهتم
بقضايا التعليم والتعلم.
لأبحاث محكمة حول التعليم الإلكتروني
وأثره على التحصيل الدراسي للطلاب
وعلى طلاب الدمج الشامل.
هل العباقرة يصنعون أم يولدون؟
لم يشغلني هذا الأمر.
ولكن شغل الكثيرين قبلي.
العباقرة يصنعون أم يولدون.
إذا كان العباقرة يولدون فلا مجال للتعب
ولامجال للبحث ولا مجال للتدريب
إذ أنهم يولدون فهي منحة
من الله سبحانه وتعالى
يمنحها لمن يشاء من عباده
إذا سيكون الأمر مقفلا والباب
موصدا فلا مجال للعبقرية
‫أما ان كان العباقرة يصنعون
فالمجال مفتوح‬ ‫للجميع
وهنا يأتي مجال التدريب والتطوير‬
‫والتهذيب والتعليمي والبحث
‫وغيره من هذه الأمور.
شغل هذا الأمر.
باحث لازلو بولغار.
عالم نفس من المجر.
اهتم لهذه القضية درس ما يقرب من أربعمئة
سيرة من سير العظماء والمثقفين
وعلماء والعباقرة في هذا الأمر
ووجد أن القاسم
الوحيد المشترك بينهم
هم انهم تعبوا على أنفسهم.
بحثوا، درسوا، تعلموا، دربوا، لم يتوقفوا
في مكان من الأمكنة.
وفي هذه اللحظة فكر في أن يصنع عباقرته.
تزوج لازلو بولغار من مدرسة من أوكرانيا.
أنجب ثلاث بنات وانتقل إلى بودابست .
أراد أن يعلمهم لعبة الشطرنج .
لماذا هذه اللعبة؟ اذ انها يمكن
للكثيرين تعلم هذه اللعبة.
يمكن للآخرين أن يجيد هذه اللعبة.
فركز على لعبة الشطرنج وكذلك بعض اللغات
الأجنبية مثل الإنجليزية والإسبانية.
والفرنسية.
بعد فترة من الزمن ليست طويلة.
ابنته الكبرى سوزان تمكنت
من إجادة لعبة الشطرنج
وهزيمة كل منافسيها تحت إحدى عشرة سنة
ابنته الأخرى.
صوفيا تمكنت من إجادة لعبة الشطرنج.
ووصلت الى المركز السادس على مستوى
العالم في هذه اللعبة،
المركز السادس عالميا.
ابنته الصغرى جوديت.
تمكنت جوديت من إجادة اللعبة على يد أبيها
ومعلميها حتى استطاعت هزيمته
في عمر الخامسة.
هزمت أبيها في هذه اللعبة في عمر الخامسة.
تربعت جوديت على عرش لعبة الشطرنج على مستوى
العالم لمدة عشرين عاما بلا منازع
بلا منازع وبلا منافس حتى وصلت الى ما يسمى
بنادي الشطرنج للرجال
ولكن لم يسمح لها النادي العالمي
للرجال بدخول هذا النادي
في هذه اللحظة لازلو بولغار استطاع أن
يقول مقولة خلدها التاريخ إلى الآن.
ان العباقرة يصنعون لا يولدون.
كل طفل يولد هو عبقري محتمل.
إذا استطعنا تدريبه استطعنا تطويره تهذيبه
استطعنا أن نغذيه بما يحتاج من المعرفة
من معلومات
في المهمة أو في الإطار أو
في الشيء الذي نريده أن ينبغي.
إذا كل طفل هو عبقري محتمل.
لا نقلل من قيمة أطفالنا، ولا من قيمتنا،
ولا من تعبنا، ولا من جهدنا مع الجميع.
هذه الصورة التي على يمينك هي لمجموعة من
الأشجار الصغيرة، جميعها ترعى بري تحظى
برعاية الطبيعة.
تسقط عليها بعض قطرات المطر.
تتسع تطلع عليها أشعة الشمس
تنبت ولكن قد لا تستمر.
تصفر أوراقها ويدق عودها
وتتساقط واحدة تلو الأخرى
إذ أنها لم تحظى بالرعاية الكاملة.
هذه الصورة الأخرى.
حينما نرعى هذه النبتة من البداية
نستطيع أن نحصل على
ثمر هذه الشجرة حينما تكبر
يكون أغصانها أو عودها قويا أشجارها مخضرة
وفي نفس الوقت تثمر قبل مثيلاتها من اشجار.
إذن العبقرية تحتاج رعاية من الصغر
تحتاج رعاية من البداية.
تحتاج التفقد إلى ما يبدعه أبناؤنا وهم
صغار لا نترك ذلك هباء منثورا.
حجر الصوان.
بحاجة لمن يطرق الشعلة الكامنة فيه.
حجر الصوان ملقى في الأرض مثله مثل باقي
الأحجار
داخله شعلة كامنة حتى نخرج هذه الشعلة
لا بد من أن يطرق بحجر آخر حتى تخرج
هذه الشعلة حتى يستطيع الناس الاستفادة
من دفء هذه الشعلة.
لا بد أن نطرق هذه الشعلة داخل حجر الصوان
لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى من يطرق هذه العبقرية
فينا وفي أبنائنا.
ما دورنا كمدربين كمعلمين
أن نلاحظ أبنائنا أن نهتم لهم
أن نلاحظ العبقرية في نفوسهم
في أي مجال ينبغي أن نساعدهم،
نحفزهم، ندعمهم، نقف معهم.
وفي نفس الوقت نراقب أعمالهم وتصرفاتهم
تدفعهم دفعا إلى العبقرية وإلى إثبات ذاتهم
ونبوغه في أي مجال كان.
وما هو دورنا.
كوالد بالبيت، الأم، الأب، الأسرة،
لا يقل دوراعن دور المدرسة،
بل هو قد يكون أكثر أهمية
إذ أنهم هم الملاصق للطفل في البيت.
إذن عليهم أن يلاحظوا هذه العبقرية
ويلاحظ تصرفات الطفل.
أي شيء يحب أي شيء يريد.
علينا أن ندعم هذا النبوغ الصغير.
علينا أن ندعم هذه العبقرية الصغيرة حتى
تثمر عبقريا كبيرا في المستقبل.
نستظل بظله ونستحق بدفئها بحرارته وقوته
حتى يكون تاجا ونبراسا في المستقبل.
ماذا علينا جميعا؟
مربين، معلمين، أولياء أمور،
مؤسسات تعليمية وتربوية هيئات
علينا جميعا أن نهتم بهذه العبقرية.
علينا أن نهتم بعبقارتنا الصغار كما قلنا.
كل طفل يولد هو عبقري محتمل.
متى إذا قمنا بتدريبه إذا قمنا بتطويره
إذا قمنا بدعمه إذا قمنا بمساعدته.
في هذه اللحظة قد نحظى بعبقرية
المستقبل في آن قريب.
في آخر شيء أود أن أوجه رسالة لي ولكم
لاتنسوا عبقريتهم ولا عبقرية أبنائكم
ابحثوا عنها اكتشفوها ادعموها بالتطوير
والتدريب والتهذيب.
وفي نهاية حديثي اقول لكم
تصبحون على عبقرية.
شكراً لكم.
(تصفيق)